Joe Biden just warned Israel to be
careful as they consider invading Gaza
in response to these Hamas attacks you
would think that Hamas would be no match
for the much stronger Israeli military
but what Biden is referring to is the
lessons the US learned after 9/11 when
our very powerful military went to
Afghanistan and Iraq and spent decades
mired in Warfare with much less powerful
Fighters but crucially fighting in
cities this thing that is much more
difficult than any other kind of warfare
military analysts told the financial
times that if Israeli soldiers invade
Gaza they're likely to find that
Fighters are actually dressed as
civilians that weapons might be stored
in mosques that houses will be rigged
with explosives and that there'll be
military facilities under schools this
will make it very difficult to fight
with militants without inflicting major
harm on civilians the US got sucked into
Decades of endless unproductive Urban
Warfare and their warning Israel to be
careful as they consider their Invasion
strategy I'm going to be following this
war to try to understand it if you want
to follow along for more